america love it or
leave it if you don't have respect in
american democracy anymore
if you don't respect madisonian checks
and balances
if your guy doesn't win if that's the
new rules of engagement
for this great republic then just leave
our country
get the facts live in the light
follow the truth and love this country
and stop this oh man what does that ass
remind you of just do
it don't let your dreams be dreams
yesterday you said tomorrow so just
do it make your dreams come true
you know maybe he should host morning
[Applause]
joe
[Music]
[Applause]
so joe biden's presidency is starting
off worse than a fox and friends cooking
segment
a lot of grease fires first the border
is a disaster
inflation is at its highest since 2008.
i did the math that's 13 years
the time it took biden to pass the bar
and then there was this
my coast guard aids have been excellent
one of them taught me that
and i quote the coast guard is that hard
nucleus about which the navy forms in
time of war
i can only assume that you will enjoy
educating your family about
how the coast guard is quote the hard
nucleus around
the navy forms in times of war
you are quite you're a really dull class
come on man is there anything joe biden
hasn't plagiarized it's too bad he
couldn't copy and paste the laughter too
i kid whichever puppeteer is controlling
him
but there's other stuff unemployment is
still higher than carly shimkus at
brunch
in biden's defense we are paying people
not to work
creating unemployment with a surplus of
jobs like jerry nadler's pants
it defies the laws of physics
so what were the press covering besides
their sorry asses
media research center assessed evening
news coverage from the first two weeks
of may
and found almost no mention of joe's
failures there's a few minutes on
inflation if you want jobs
nothing on the border instead they spent
a combined 33 minutes on liz cheney
yeah the most important thing going on
in america is republicans removing an
unpopular
republican not that your savings are
shrinking i mean if you're going to rank
stories in order of importance to
average americans
this story would come in slightly higher
than a guy finding a cheeto that looks
like jesus
but liz didn't seem to mind she soaked
up the attention like kill mead at a
nude beach
[Laughter]
i call it the strange new earned respect
disorder
or snerd for short snirting is when
people who hate you suddenly like you
because you're useful
and since the attention feels good you
go right along with the snerd herd
it happened with mitts it happened with
adam kinzinger
it happened with barry manilow when he
joined the manson family
that didn't happen i just needed a
fourth example
but it's also happening to the
bald-headed pinheads of the lincoln
project but they're too dumb to realize
it yet
so as the media flocked to liz what did
she say
i will do everything i can
to ensure that the former president
never again gets anywhere near the oval
office
that's some goal not doing what your
constituents want
but what makes you feel good that's like
hosting a new show and showing nothing
but pictures of your dog
[Laughter]
that'll get back to her but i get it i
mean after being hated for so long it's
nice to have the press pretending you're
human
the word there of course is pretending
it's like that fake friend from school
who gives you bad advice
because they have their own agenda sure
you can study for the test on the bus in
the morning
now shut up and shotgun this can of cold
45.
hey darla if you get pregnant you'll be
the most famous person in algebra
or sure her i think you can make it from
the roof
to the swimming pool never should have
said that to seth
he doesn't call me anymore he doesn't
call anyone anymore
that's the media they want you to do
stuff that's good for them
and bad for you a labor department
report shows core inflation growing at
its highest rate since april 1982.
that was when cat was only 10. cbs
evening news
gave it only 11 seconds which is the
same amount of time it takes me to climb
to the top of tyrus
like he's a human rock wall the reason
for inflation
the stimulus that's what happens when
you pump more money into the system
it's supply and demand a larger amount
of money competes for the same amount of
stuff so the stuff gets more expensive
and the money loses value it's like what
happened to brian kilmeade
they overexposed him diminishing a great
product
yes but the media pushed the stimulus so
now
their mom i wonder what the angry white
male thinks
oh hey just hanging upside down by my
ankles
you know i don't trust the mainstream
media at all
anymore and i've never been happier i
saved so much time not reading the new
york times
it allows me to do all the things i
really want to do like hang upside down
by my ankles
when i hang upside down by my ankles all
the blood rushes to my head
and it gives me a peaceful feeling
sometimes i stay here until the world
seems right side up
and then when i turn right side up the
world seems upside down
you should try it
or maybe not
i'm worried about him so once again you
get what the press
wants you to get there are information
overlords who crave control
it wasn't always this way centuries ago
the first reporter only jotted down
notes of village activities
no one minded because it kept him from
the sheep
his stories would be something like
goats seen in forest looking confused
or the cobbler soiled himself in the
park or journalist mounts goat in effort
to scare cobbler
then they got self-important and began
injecting their opinions into stories
the earth is flat women and minorities
hit hardest
the press morphed from insignificant to
powerful because they wrote their own
narrative
and created their own awards they would
be the protagonists in all of their
stories
fearless deeply moral and lying because
lying embellishes dull stories
and it's okay to be unethical if you
think you're right plus destroying
people is exciting
it's why today local stories are now
national oh someone left a mean message
on a restaurant receipt
stop the presses let's ruin someone for
a click
today the mainstream media is an
ecosystem of gossip columnists pushing
conflict for attention
because they're not because they're not
hot or talented enough to be famous in
any other industry present company
excluded
today's press is less legitimate than a
guy in an orange jumpsuit
claiming to be your uber driver it might
not be the oldest profession in history
but it might as well be because all it
does is screw people
[Applause]
luch welcome tonight's guest
he's our number one guest when we can't
get steve ducey
fox and friends co-host brian kilby
if you think your smile is bright you
should see her brain
although that would require surgery fox
news headlines 24 7 reporter carly
shimkus
his parents named him chadwick because
wentworth dansby the third was taken
editor of outspoken and the spectator
called this chad with moore
[Applause]
she's like a sewing needle skinny sharp
and very popular with old people
fox news contributor cat tim
all right brian you have never broken a
story
but but don't you think you're more of a
journalist than a
so-called reporters are because at least
you're true to yourself
yes i'm trying to get over should i
should you apologize before you
introduce me
i've been through so much but again i've
said nothing so
what i think is i used to enjoy flipping
around to see what the competition's
doing
now i see fiction and non-fiction right
and i i don't even know what they're
focusing on i mean you would think if
you flip around the other channels
january 6th and then there's january 6th
yes and then there's what is donald
trump doing
and did i mention january 6th yeah and
there is so much legitimately going on
and here's what i find
heartening about it is you don't need as
much as you need the gut felt show
you don't need the gut felt show to know
that everything's more expensive
you don't need the gut felt show to know
there's a long line suddenly for gas
that was once a dollar ninety-eight
right
or how much your house is worth or how
oppressive your state
is so i think i'll move to a state that
isn't so people are making their
judgment not waiting for the next
30-second spot have i gone over my time
i since when you nod quickly
it's like i should wrap it up oh i was
thinking about what i was gonna order
today from uh so you're not even paying
attention i'm not even sure what you're
saying at that point
no i agree with you completely i agree
with that when people turn on the news
they know they're being lied to because
all they have to do is look out the
window
carly i have a golden rule if the press
suddenly likes you you're betraying
yourself you have to be suspicious
like take um michael cohen they hated
michael cohen
trump lawyer and then all of a sudden
he's like their best friend because they
can use him for
like seven minutes trump hate and you
know speaking of likability i think what
we're seeing
happen right now is that um a lot of
people voted for
uh biden because of his personality
because he was nice and trump was mean
and we're
really starting to see what happens when
you have a president who wants to please
everybody you do things like you give
money to both
iran and palestine you um green light
the
russia pipeline uh to please germany you
don't wear a mask inside when you're
sitting next to the 96 year old former
president and then you put one
on for the cameras outside because it's
all about optics and it's all about
applause
president trump was the exact opposite
he obviously didn't care what people
thought about him
and he went in there like a wrecking
ball and said you know nato needs to pay
more
uh the the iran nuclear deal doesn't
make sense neither does the uh climate
the paris climate accord
and he his goal was really to make
america strong it really feels like joe
biden's goal is to maintain that
popularity and likeability yeah that's
true
you know chadwick you're not as
good-looking as i am
right does it bother you that optics
matter more than content
i think it's just it's in terms of the
news
what a question
uh uh you know it's this is just how
they this is the game now this is
who they are now yes um and they're
they're so
shameless they don't even care yeah they
don't hide it the only clicks they get a
rage click so i'm just judging on social
media
which is probably good for them i'm not
sure who's watching it's the airport
people i guess that's it for one of the
networks
yes uh but it's it's it's shameless it
and it
they feel they had this energy like a
drug addict
about to hit rock bottom five dollars
left
scrambling anything they just need that
next hit they don't know what tomorrow's
gonna bring but they cannot
help themselves yeah yeah they need
trump they need they need trump they
need him back exactly
who needs trump the cuomos because
they're eating the libs are eating
themselves
because they don't they don't have the
massive trump buffet
that kept them fat and now they're just
tearing each other apart cat
you understand that feeling oh yeah
tearing
things apart yes uh yeah well i i saw a
theory recently when it comes to biden
av
stoddard at real clear politics said he
thinks that they expected that he was
going to be president in a divided
government
that the um then georgia happened
so they were going to say okay we'll do
all this liberal stuff and we'll say
this to
you know please it progresses but none
of it will ever actually have to happen
because
you know the the the senate is going to
be republican and i think that makes a
lot of sense
because a lot of people have done things
like that you know like if you're
you say yes i can headline and then you
know you're like oh i only have five
minutes like that's the same feeling
that
you invite somebody out to go somewhere
because you don't think they'll come and
then they show up
happens all the time because it is
really such a complete mess and i think
it's because they weren't prepared for
it
yeah i think though if you stop and you
think about the media
it's a layer of subjective it's a it's
it's a variable
a subjective interpretation of life so
that when you put it into any kind of
environment
it changes it even though it's not even
part of it and so like would
i keep thinking if the media wasn't
around last year would we have had riots
we probably wouldn't have had riots uh
would race be this much of an issue if
there wasn't a media
and i'm not saying we shouldn't have a
media but i'm not saying we should not
not have a media i don't even know what
i just said right
i would say it's not helping instead of
reporting it's changing
yes it's like there's the american
people uh in
in this case i'm sure there's a renegade
or a spin-off gutfeld show in britain
yes like we spun off the office very
successful yes yes uh so
for in america we got what's happening
and then what the media wants to tell
you what's happening
so they're running their own show yes
you know and the thing is
there is no there's no ground to it i
i'm just astounded too
you could take it apart obviously i like
this channel the best this be
and that's what i would say on camera
off camera but if you look at the
ratings
for the longest time america likes this
channel the best do you know the
cnn didn't break a one all day when you
did red eye
yes you were doubling that you're
talking about people that can't get at
six
six p.m yeah as opposed to two ways that
i was redeye was beating
morning joe at three a.m and they were
on like what at eight all right we got
to stop
boasting about how awesome we are sell
some math sorry about that that's okay
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else